hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the uh semi-finals of the
chesable masters knockouts it's dingler
and versus magnus carlsen and we have
yet another game uh that falls victim to
the rapids time control the game did not
live up to its full potential but you
guys are luckily here to rectify this
and you've seen in the previous game
where ding played against magnus ding
had a winning position but it was um an
impossible move to find where well here
it's uh
it's gonna be similar uh to that so if
you
if you guys enjoyed those lines you guys
will enjoy these lines as well so ding
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 c for e6 knights
to c3 and we have the nimzo indian
defense bishop to b4
we have e3 biting and now castles by
magnus knight f3 and now c5 striking in
the center going for the hebrew
variation bishop to d3 and now d5
grabbing the full center we have c
captures on the e5e characters and d
captures on c5 capturing away from the
center this is how modern chess is
played and now magnus goes for bishop to
g4 here knight b to d7 is the
continuation that is considered the the
safest but bishop to g4 is just
something that you would see in uh in a
school book i i mean you just spin those
knights and you have a great game so
this is what what magnus is doing
against ding here we have castles and
not knight b to d7 bishop to d2 uh and
interestingly magnus already had this
position in 2017 in leuven uh against
wesley saw only with magnus having the
white pieces here where wesley played
bishop captures on f3 and wesley won
that game with the black pieces however
here
magnus plays rook to c8 and it is now as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game
so magnus deviates from the game that he
himself lost with the white pieces to
wesley's bishop captures on f3
and now comes the bishop back to e2 yeah
ding says all right you have um
quite the pressure there i'm now ready
to un pin and bishop captures on c5 we
have queen to b3 now dean goes after the
d5 pawn and the b7 pawn and the magnus
says that's exactly what i wanted bishop
to d6 and here magnus sacrifices the d5
pawn for the attack those bishops are
looking really awesome
knight captures on d5 knight captures
queen captures and now comes knight to
e5 and here uh the tension is incredible
uh you can you you can really feel it
and there should be should be something
here and ding ding spots it uh correctly
here uh ding's uh spidey sense is
definitely tingling rook after d1 uh
makes sense you want to put pressure on
that bishop and the queen if the uh if
the d file clears up uh and the idea
behind knight captures an e5 uh which of
course can be played is that after
bishop captures on e2 uh black is just
uh well
better or almost winning or maybe even
just winning because okay the rook is
attacked after you move the rook there's
this incredible bishop to c4 and now
white has to give up the queen uh if you
if you play knight captures on c4 then
of course the bishop captures and h2
wins the queen this way so
not not a lot of fun so like i said rook
after d1 great move by ding and now
magnus plays
rook to c2 and this is now big problem
but not for ding this is a big problem
for magnus the position is not
completely winning for ding if he
manages to find the correct idea luckily
you guys are here feel free to pause the
video and win the game for ding while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on crushing the
reigning world champion in only 15 moves
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the movies bishop to b4
that's the move but it seems that for
this game it was too difficult to
calculate or magnus just again uh
successfully employed a mind trick
towards ding and the ding missed this
idea he probably checked it and he said
all right magnus probably calculated it
well
i'm not gonna
search any further but after bishop to
b4 there is no move for black
what
sorry for yeah for black what do you
play here obviously we're threatening to
win material so how can how can you
counter this there are some lines for
example you could play rook captures on
e2 white's bishop on e2 is also hanging
but this doesn't help you after rook
captures on e2 we're just going to play
knight captures on e5
uh and uh well
that's it
there are no more moves again the bishop
is saying you can't move it if the
bishop moves we're just gonna pick up
the queen and of course if you go bishop
the c7 which seems like a move you can
do well then just knight captures on g4
as the bishop and g4 is also hanging so
uh there's uh there's no move you can
make so after bishop to b4 rook capture
72 obviously doesn't work what does work
for black is knight captures an f3 this
is one such line that we are going to
discuss and now after g captures an f3
because you want to keep attacking the
bishop and the bishop on d6 now we have
rook captures on e2 but now again what
do you play here uh well just captures
on g4 and after queen to h4 it seems
like black is the one that's winning now
going for the h2 pawn and also the f2
pawn uh not really just queen captures
uh or even better bishop captures than
d6 you guard the h2 point and you allow
queen captures and have to do completely
crazy stuff and after queen captures
king h1 there is no more attack and also
the rook here is hanging so once you
move the rook we're going to play queen
captures on b7 and it looks like black
maybe has compensation for the piece but
not really with the bishop controlling
the dark scores and with the queen
controlling this diagonal there is
nothing black can do here let's say
queen captures an e3 we just move the
bishop and this is um uh as capoblanca
would say unassailable
uh that's
there's just no good way to continue the
game uh for uh for black so uh we have
to go back all the way to bishop to b4
is there even a move that magnus could
play here well there is but again it's
not much it is knight captures an f3
with check g captures and now not rook
captures on uh e2 but rather bishop
captures an h2 which means that if now
king captures queen the h4 check will be
winning for black however if you play
just king to g2 now there aren't any
good continuations your best bet here is
to just trade queens and once you trade
queens uh for example queen captures
rook captures now you have to deal with
this hanging this hanging and let's say
bishop b6 you go after the rook we play
bishop d1 we go after black's rook after
rook captures on b2 attacking the bishop
we pick up the rook on f8 king captures
on f8 and now rook to h5 moving through
a cut of arms away again with tempo the
bishop is still hanging bishop to c7 and
we now have this in the game where we
let's say go bishop b3 go after the
bishop here let's say captures captures
and now black can uh choose between
capturing here and allowing rook
captures on a7 or defended the pawn
let's say with bishop here but then we
capture this pawn and this is the
resulting end game uh two rooks against
the rook and the bishop uh where okay
you will pick up this pawn you will have
two connected passports on the queen
side but it will not be enough white
will set up a very nice uh
uh two rook combo on the seventh you
will start picking up
pawns and that's just it so uh tough
luck for ding because he missed the
bishop the b4 again uh seems as as if
because magnus allowed it
obviously
it's not good and the ding did not
search for it so he just moved the
bishop back bishop to e1 now okay uh
he's attacking the bishop here but now
magnus just trades everything off rook
captures on e2 knight captures on e5
with bishop characters and e5 queen
captures on e5 and now
uh as uh well your rook does look a bit
funny there but uh luckily the bishop
and queen are attacking the rook on d1
so it just real captures an e3
interestingly this is the only move that
doesn't lose for uh for magnus because
if you if you just move the queen or do
something weird uh we're gonna we're
gonna win that um
uh we're gonna win that rook on e2 so uh
if rook captures an e3 wasn't possible
then there's just nothing here so rook
captures an e3 now attacking the queen
so you could just trade on this way or
you could trade on this way queen
captures an e3 bishop captures on d1
queen captures on a7 and now queen to d5
and now we have this end game
where ding is up a pawn but can he do
something with this pawn so bishop to c3
we have rook to e8 and now h3 creating a
breeding room for the king magnus does
the same we have h6 and now queen to d4
adding offers a queen trade and also
threatens checkmate so magnus trades
captures captures and now that bishop
back to a4 not allowing the rook to
capture it of course b sorry b3
attacking the bishop bishop to c6 and
now pawn to a4 so here ding still has
the uh two connected uh pawns here and
uh he will at some point push them all
the way and maybe create a pass pawn so
rook to e4 attacks the bishop bishop c5
now rookie 5 harassing the bishop bishop
to e3 we have rook to e4 bishop to c5
rook to e5 and now b4 the pawns start
marching forward rook to g5 going after
the g2 pawn and just g4 so here it seems
like you are allowing a bit too much the
magnus but the ding has everything
perfectly calculated f5 with b5 now
attacking the bishop bishop to f3 and
now bishop to e3 attacking the rook rook
to g6 and now king h2 seemingly losing a
pawn but not really because after magnus
plays uh f captures on g4 i think has
king to g3 now of course you cannot
capture because king captures the bishop
so bishop back to e2 and now uh we have
rook to c1 not uh
not bothered with this pawn okay you
will be down upon but um
you have all the counter play so
captures on h3 king captures and now
rook to f6 so you're not down upon now
as you were up upon now it's equal
material uh rook to c5 and now bishop to
d3 uh we have a5 being ready to create a
pass pawn here uh now comes rook f5
forcing a rook trade now because if you
move of course pawns start falling
sorrow captures on f5 bishop captures
and knocking the g3 and he was in this
position on mu 41 that magnus and the
ding agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here once uh
let's say king to f7 is played and a
pass pawn is created for example
captures captures there's just no way to
reach the light square because we have a
dark square bishop magnus has a light
square bishop he's just gonna put the
bishop let's say on c6 he's going to
control this diagonal and that's it
there's no playing this
uh so after king to g3 not a great draw
for ding because second game uh against
magnus being completely winning but
magnus uh
got into got to him and uh ding just
didn't believe that magnus would allow
such a position to appear on the board
on on move 15 but bishop to b4
completely crushing so congratulations
to everyone who who founded this and i
know you guys already watched that b4
square it has to be something with b4
and yes you are correct the most often
uh more often than not it it usually you
know the winning idea involves the b4
square
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for recommending it
as soon as it ended uh we're gonna cover
some more games um uh from the other
match as well so keep suggesting i would
like to thank david kimura adam simmons
robert key for mark manor and nagarjuna
ponogoti for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
generally covering the event uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you're
wondering why meadow wasn't in the
videos today again there is a fish being
cooked downstairs and the meadow refuses
to leave the fish
so there you have it see you soon